okay
all right jay yes jay where'd you grow
up where are you from originally
milwaukee wisconsin
and tell me about your childhood you had
both your parents when you were young
um yeah they were both there um my dad
eventually left when i was about 12.
how would you describe your childhood um
it was tumultuous uh
very um
i don't know dysfunctional and
my parents are both kind of like absent
most of the time like i was just kind of
on my own really for the most part
so no abuse or anything like that yeah
there was
um a lot of verbal some physical um
they're both alcoholics so
yeah your siblings yes two older sisters
indeed and you uh you finished school
i did finish high school yeah what did
you do after that um
not much i drank for a few years and
then i ended up
just getting on the ground and coming
out to san francisco
so you've been you've been out here
since 2012
2002 um yeah and what did you do when
you got here
um well i continued to drink for a
little while and
i moved out here with my best friend at
the time and she ended up going to
treatment
and um i kind of just
graduated into narcotics
and um basically just
you know i'm partying running around the
tenderloin
and what is your what is your drug now
my job now um
fentanyl and crack cocaine
and you're living where um in a hotel in
lombard
with my friend yeah and so you're
supporting yourself
the way a lot of the girls will support
themselves here i'm assuming um
well i actually will
try to do any hustle to avoid actually
doing any sex work but um
i do a lot of delivery um
for methamphetamine
and then i'm also a doctor which is
um i assist people in injecting
drugs safely was it right yes
i do it they uh you know or
they know i'm responsible for them being
able to get high so they
pretty much take care of me pretty well
so it works out good okay
yeah but do you still have contact with
your family
i do i do yeah and they know what you're
doing or you where you're at
yeah i'm pretty open and honest about
everything
so yeah you know what's what's their
reaction
um they worry a lot um
they try to encourage me to come home um
i don't know they just
they um yeah um
i caused them a lot of worry yeah
yeah unfortunately
i try to raise from that um
i'm
a lot safer than a lot of people
i think um i don't do anything too
reckless or
i don't put myself in any compromising
situations as long as i can
help it um yeah
i don't know and drug use for you
started at what age
before you came out to san francisco
yeah um
i was 16 when i first started doing
narcotics who introduced you to them
um my dad always had um
pills and stuff around and i just knew
it was just known that he like you know
was a pill
popper so you know like i would
eventually started stealing him stealing
them from him until he
started giving them to me
your parents are both addicts yes and
are they still using today
um my mom isn't my dad is
and looking back at your life what do
you have
regrets any decisions you made that you
wish you hadn't or anything like that
yeah definitely
um i regret uh
not being more present for my nieces and
nephews and them growing up
um
i regret not um
i don't know just
taking more opportunities and just kind
of going
with my gut more instead of denying
myself all the time and talking myself
out of things a lot
um yeah have you been in love before
yeah yes i have can you tell me about
that
oh it's um
the most amazing beautiful
indescribable experience i've ever had
and also the
most devastating and painful
what was that just the breakup or um
i think um the breakup was a relief
that was a better part i think towards
the end but um
no just having to face um
[Music]
yourself and um
having to face all the ugly things you
know
about yourself as well as the beautiful
things and um
also having to accept that about the
person you love um
and having to remember in the end that
you're both just human beings
you know and um we both make mistakes
and nothing is forever and
nobody's perfect you know
what's the most important lesson you've
learned
that um
only i'm
in control of whether i'm
you know in pain or feel good or
only i'm in control of being hurt
and dealing with um negativity
i only let
i only allow
that's my responsibility of what
goes on in my life and what i'm affected
by and what i
choose to be a part of and the way i
allowed it happened to me it was
in under my control only so
yeah do you feel like the fact that your
parents like you grew up with
parents that were addicts may have
opened up the door for you to do the
same it sounds like you're raiding your
dad's pill
pills early yeah um
it definitely um made it easier and
more prevalent i think i would have
probably either anyway anyway i would
have
you know
became an addict myself regardless yeah
and living this life for
yeah you you're on the tenderloin and
there's lots of drugs and crime and
prostitution all that kind of stuff
going on all around you is that
does that get depressing for you does it
get on your nerves after a while is it
um extremely yeah it's a a small
small little area with a a
large amount of negative concentrated
negative energy
so it's um constantly overwhelming and
it's um you get depressed sometimes all
the time
yeah um
i um
i don't know i uh
remain disconnected as much as possible
and um
try to be not present as much as
possible so yeah what do you think the
solution might be for you
discipline
i don't know do you think loving
yourself could be
a part of the solution yeah
you know sometimes the shame that you
feel and stuff like that
gets you know sabotage you know it just
creates self-sabotages
it makes it hard to
have a somewhat normal functional
human interaction or
you know makes it interpersonal
relationships difficult
for sure do you have kids no
i don't
i thought maybe you were transgender
when i first met you because you are
you are i am oh i didn't know i was
wondering i thought maybe you might be
yeah i am oh you are very
you had me fooled god's got a weird
sense of humor i suppose i guess
and was that part of the problem with uh
your family and
no they took it well yeah surprisingly i
was really lucky
yeah compared to most people so
pretty supportive family and yeah that's
great
and being a transgender woman that makes
it tougher out here
it's i don't feel like anything's
more difficult or anything is you know
harder
than it is for anybody else you know i
don't
i don't buy into that whole you know
you don't buy into it i don't i don't i
feel like
you know
it's just you know a different scenario
different details yeah same [ __ ] you
know what what was the best part of your
life
best memories best time
it's a good question um
probably the three years i was married
to my husband isaac yeah well first time
in my life
how many years ago was that um six
and how did that fall apart um
he was a severely paranoid schizophrenic
and
um but it took in a lot of stimulants as
well so that made it um
a million times worse so he ended up
taking his own life
oh he did yeah i'm sorry it's okay it's
not your fault
part of life definitely part of life
what do you look forward to for your
future your hopes of
doing anything backpacking through
europe
studying history good for you yeah
that's my i uh my skeleton plan
that's great yeah i'm excited
i'm looking forward to it well jay thank
you so much for sharing your story
yeah i wish you the best of luck and i
hope you make it to europe
thank you we do all right thank you
thanks